hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Doctor Who Christmas special video
hopefully you guys have been having an
awesome holiday this is kind of like a
one-off Doctor Who episode so even if
you're not like super familiar with the
river song character this is just like
meant to be a really fun romantic comedy
story careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet I'm gonna
be referencing a whole bunch of specific
stuff like it's very Easter Egg heavy
Steven Moffat wrote the episode he's
like the biggest self-described original
angry who fan so his scripts always tend
to have more references to other Doctor
Who episodes than any other writer so
let's just start with top 5 WTF moments
number 5 the TARDIS puts antlers on the
doctors head I love the idea that the
TARDIS gets the doctor into the holiday
spirit without the doctor realizing it
number 4
usually people need a flowchart to
understand our relationship just to
explain what's going on with the doctor
and River in this episode it's is pretty
clear like when they first meet River
doesn't recognize him at all because she
doesn't know the 13th face of the doctor
and I know there's always like the
running joke about like you know even
though it's the 12th doctor technically
it says 13th face because of the war
doctor like when they unfurled the
rolodex of pictures be on the lookout
for one of these twelve faces the war
doctors in there but there's no Capaldi
picture so rivers trying to steal this
diamond she wants the doctor's help so
she like she purposefully tries to land
herself in his path but she has no idea
that the Time Lords gave the doctor a
new set of regeneration so he has a
totally different face if you're
confused about River Song here's like a
very quick flow chart so River is the
daughter of Doctor Who companions Amy
and Rory because she was conceived on
the TARDIS she was exposed to art on
energy so she kind of became somewhat of
a Time Lady sudo time lady she was able
to regenerate but during series 6 during
Matt Smith's run they do this big
season-long River Song art where amy has
her baby it gets stolen by the silence
and turned into a weapon to fight the
doctor build a weapon with the powers of
a Time Lord to fight a Time Lord
so as the baby river gets stolen taken
away and is raised away from Amy in Rory
like she doesn't know her parents
growing up eventually we meet adult
River Song who has been like fully
weaponized tries to kill the doctor but
the doctor charming is the Oasis wins
her over
she turns into the good river song that
we meet during most of the other times
that we've seen her in episodes but
she's completely batshit crazy that
that's part of the fun of the character
so during the series six episode let's
kill Hitler River Song
gives up her regenerations all her
remaining regenerations to save the
doctors life and that's kind of the
beginning of their relationship but the
big twist of their relationship is is
that they experience each other's
timelines in opposite directions so as
the doctor gets to know her more she
knows him less and less so the comedy is
is that when the Matt Smith doctor meets
her for the first time he doesn't know
her at all but she gives him like this
big kiss and he's like I don't I don't
understand what's the what why are you
kissing me she explains what's going on
and then like he slowly gets to know her
in their relationship develops now the
other big thing that's going on in this
episode is that it's closing the River
Song art like we're seeing her right
before she sees the doctor for the last
time in a David Tennant episode that
happened years ago that's much higher in
my WTF list so one of my number three
WTF River Song goes from the sonic
trowel to the official sonic screwdriver
that the doctor gave her now in her
first ever appearance in silence in the
library she has a sonic screwdriver in
the doctor's like where the f did you
get that because you could have only
gotten that from a Time Lord or from me
did you know did you steal it off of
someone this is big mystery so we
finally find out when the doctor gave
her that sonic I guess he just couldn't
bear the sight of a sonic trowel it did
look pretty silly number two WTF the
doctor finally gets to do the bigger on
the inside speech I wanted to see it
done proper for once and then the fact
is that River Song still kind of went up
so when she opens the liquor cabinet and
the TARDIS that the doctor didn't know
about Capaldi has like the most amazing
reaction phases and in the funny thing
about River Song like if you're not a
big River Song fan like if you haven't
seen a lot of her episodes is that the
joke is she always knows more about the
TARDIS than the doctor does I think one
of the funniest River Song TARDIS jokes
is when she tells the doctor that it's
not supposed to make that whooshing
sound that's the sound that it makes
when the parking brakes are on so it's
almost like the doctor like that all
these you know 50 years that has been on
television the doctor has been flying
the TARDIS with the parking brake on
constantly so just imagine like a
stormtrooper telling another
stormtrooper
like dude tie fighters they're not
supposed to make that sound that's what
the joke is but but of course I know my
number one WTF River and the doctor meet
for the last time but big caveat the
Knights on that planet last for 24 years
I hate you know you don't know the big
Matt Smith joke if you go back and you
watch series 6 like they say that a lot
where rivers like I hate you in the Matt
Smith doctors like no you don't so there
are a few classic who references like
showing all the doctors faces but most
of the references to previous Doctor Who
episodes in this episode are two other
River Song episodes so if you've only
watched new who you will catch most of
the references but if you don't know
anything about River Song or you just
want to watch her stuff start with
silence in the library
you know this is a great episode but I
still feel like silence in the library
is my favorite River Song story that's
when she ends up dying but she gets
uploaded into a computer so you could
argue that she's not dead but her
physical body is gone but just because
this is closing the River Song arc
doesn't mean there won't be more
adventures so that's what the doctors
line at the very end was like this might
be our last night but this isn't our
last adventure together so like River
Song will have other adventures with
other doctors but in the strictest of
terms yeah this is kind of like the last
big River Song episode that we're
probably going to see but you will
probably hear more River Song jokes in
the future and I think Alex Kingston
will probably do audio dramas like even
John Barrowman comes back to do Captain
Jack audio dramas so if he can do that
then River Song will totally do audio
dramas too let me know in the comments
like what was your favorite moment from
this episode like was it her getting the
Sonic or was it the comedy of her not
recognizing the doctor and then suddenly
being like oh my god it's you god damn
it
it really is a heartwarming touching
episode but if you really don't like
River Song I feel like it was kind of a
weird episode for you it almost reminded
me a little bit of voyage of the Damned
which was another Christmas episode but
during the David Tennant years and it
didn't really involve any of the other
Fant like he was by himself think space
Titanic crashing another big ship
crashing just to talk about a few of the
big Easter eggs like the big one is the
towers of Dalaran the singing towers the
last place they ever meet the first time
that's referenced is during force to the
Dead is the second part of the silence
in the library story it's like river
songs very first story so like the first
time you see her she
references the last time they ever meet
each other rivers die Rita the big prop
that's used heavily in the episode that
was also given to her by the doctor at
the end of let's kill Hitler like when
they first turned her from the dark side
but here's a list of all the River Song
appearances if you just if you want to
watch them and order or you want to
watch them out of order starting with
series 4 silence in the library forced
to the dead then series 5 time of angels
flesh and stone another two-part episode
then the Pandorica opens the Big Bang
that was actually the finale from series
she was used heavily during series 6
because we got to see her birth and the
baby got stolen went back and took me in
a very River heavy season there's
Impossible Astronaut then day of the
Moon good man goes to war let's kill
Hitler probably played one of the better
River episodes closing time then the
wedding of River Song another really big
event in her life the next drink series
7 there's the Angels Take Manhattan the
name of the doctor and then finally now
like this Christmas episode the husbands
of River Song so she was in 15 different
episodes but some of those were two
parters mostly during the Matt Smith era
but she started during David Tennant's
run and she was actually created by
Steven Moffat silence in the library
force to the dead those are Steven
Moffat episodes I know a lot of you guys
are asking about the Sherlock Christmas
special and Doctor Who series 10 all I
know about Doctor Who series 10 is that
it's going to be a full series Moffat
like who cares about budget cuts we're
doing a full series but the Sherlock
Christmas special is actually airing on
New Year's Day so it's still gonna be a
couple more days before that comes but I
will do a video for it so be sure to
subscribe to get that Sherlock is a bit
of a weird deal if you haven't watched
it before it's all on Netflix so
definitely check it out before the
Christmas special there's only three
series they only do three episodes per
series so it's like a really easy watch
speaking of Martin Freeman Benedict
Cumberbatch I'm working on a new Captain
America Civil War video
Martin Freeman is in Captain America
Civil War Benedict Cumberbatch's Doctor
Strange in the Marvel Universe now why
his way for me to finish that you can
click here for all my other Doctor Who
videos from this year and you can click
here for the Deadpool red band trailer
from Christmas red boat keV and you can
click here for the Deadpool red band
trailer from Christmas thank you
so much watching remaining 45 or see you
guys tonight